so this this is about the origins of the
virus not the epidemic obviously the
epidemic is an epidemic
IV but there wasn't always HIV HIV is
new virus hundred years let's say pretty
much in the form it's in now and the the
thing is that in our work over the years
now my coat my co-authors of Preston
marks who's a leading simian biologist
in the country is the editor of the
journal of the author of the textbook
and ahead of the primate Center the
infection is the immunology part of the
primate Center in New Orleans a two lane
where our grant is based burning it's an
NIH funded project now operating in
Brazzaville in the Congo and bill
Schneider is we've been working at this
15 years that built in five years only
but Preston and I were met it on an
aeroplane we're looking at the origin of
AIDS why aids at this time because the
monkey virus is that this comes from our
very old hundreds of thousands a year
old the a in this case chimpanzees ape
not a monkey but you notice the HIV s is
more than one HIV I don't mean type M
typo I mean hiv-1 and hiv-2 and those
are different viruses that come from a
different simian species and it's very
important to the artbook cut to that
there's a we had a conference in Paris
in in 2010 about the larger issue of
simian virus emerging diseases emerging
viral diseases the rubric under which
this goes in public health and
epidemiology and the this website we can
send it out to you if you want that you
find it easily enough has that
conference a three-day conference and
it's a beautiful job they did with films
of the speakers in one box and the power
points in another box and its really
well produced the French do a nice job
on this at the Sorbonne and you can see
the entire conference than any of you
are interested in emerging viral disease
some of the best people in the world are
there yes I snuck in
helped organize so let me go to the
point it's a tale about Africa and you
know that the notion that aids came out
of Africa which is true first cases
moved out into the wider world from
Africa where they were with where they
emerged and in fact hiv-1 the hiv-1
epidemic pretty much as far as we can
tell traces back to Kinshasa in 1950s I
year at the time the cargo now and
that's Central Africa as I year when
this map was made and we were in the
Republic of Congo right across Kinshasa
in a place called brazzaville which the
which was a French Equatorial Africa
whereas the congos I year was Belgian
property and here's the research
question that drives this the problem
that they're in fact two separate HIV
epidemics HIV 1 & 2 they emerge at about
the same time and the oldest known case
example of a virus that was frozen away
from a hepatitis study was from 1959 so
we know the virus exists in its human
form by 59 so that that's it that's a
point to remember this because something
happens before 1959 to create that virus
it happened five thousand years ago did
it happen over a hundred years did it
have you don't wait and the importance
of that is that emerging viruses leaving
an animal reservoir and moving to it to
humans is something that's happening all
the time hepatitis was not in the human
population 300 years ago and now it's
more prevalent by a factor of 10 that
HIV is in the human population
fortunately it's not as lethal as
quickly but it's a very serious issue so
the problem to to fully adapted epidemic
strength so I've been come a student of
epidemic of invar of evolutionary
biology and the thing is fully adapted
viruses means in to the virologists who
study this means that they can reproduce
through
human-to-human transmission sexual
transmission airborne to transmit the
reason the reason scare or you see the
movie contagion which i think is a very
good job of this actually and i actually
ian ian is a what's higgins last name
lip getting looking at columbia is our
works with us on this this research
looking for new strains of viruses but
the the idea that viruses moved from one
species to another that you know the
famous kind of cooking part of this in
parts of asia where different animal
species are kept in cages above each
other and they mix up what they the
viruses from their droppings and their
urine and it's just a constant process
of pushing out new viruses which
challenge themselves against you any
species that's around that handles them
so the people handle these viruses got
bird flu and got SARS but they mostly
didn't transmit to other people and
that's why this reason scare about a new
engineered form of bird virus that could
break through to become an airborne or
droplet born or a touch borne virus so
the fact that the two viruses the 2 1
hiv-1 and to which I before I got into
this 15 years ago believed when it come
from the other item 2 came after one so
two came from and it's not true they
came from a different place they came
from a different species and we can
trace the lineage of viruses very very
well now and see where they came from
not only well but how long they came
from here to there because the number of
mutations in a way put what's called a
molecular clock on the process those
tree diagrams you see are also time
diagrams and finally the human exposure
to these has been forever people always
hunted and butchered and got bit by and
got blood exposure from the animals that
they hunted and these animals in the
case of hiv-1 chimpanzees in central
Africa the this this pictures that got
deleted from oh no they're here ok let's
bushmeat that's what it was about it was
about getting it was like people in the
South hunting squirrels and deer just no
difference at all this
a mandrill endangered species and here's
the process we're talking about okay
ugly but real and part of life and if
you go to an abattoir and you were in
the world people get blood in their
hands so the exposure you know what's
going on forever so what happened and we
know from the Vark from the molecular
examination of the DNA of the simian
virus is that 75% of simian species
carry a prototype of a retrovirus that
forms the basis of evolving into HIV is
in various ways that that those viruses
are hundreds of thousands of years old
and people have hunted and butchered
those animals for that period of time so
why suddenly in in the mid-twentieth
century do we see the emerge it's not
just of an epidemic but if new virus but
but of new viruses none that crossover
wasn't like rabies exposing a person to
rabies where they catch and things from
the animal or this or this engineered
form of bird flu this virus had to
transform itself the number of DNA
changes from it to the human virus is
substantial it doesn't just happen from
a version a particular case of the virus
and a monkey that happens to be close
enough that it can skip over to a human
and become and become epidemic in humans
where it has to replicate in the human
with sufficient vigor and sufficiently
productive to shed off viral material in
the envelope that that's used in sexual
transmission that's what's being
transmitted as pieces of the virus
sufficient to to infect to establish an
infection even today the
the in a single dose of infective
material let's say semen or a blood from
a human being to another fewer than
three percent of the viruses that
establish an infection are actually
capable of establishing infection
because meet a thing is mutating very
rapidly and most of the products are
defective and it's the rare proportion
of those and that's one of the reasons
why the sexual transmission rate is so
low the discordant couples where someone
should be should be infected how come
they're not well it because the chance
that gets of it's a Russian roulette
with is a thousand Behrend rooms were a
thousand bullets and only two or three
of them have bullets in it anyway I want
to go through the story so that was our
that's that's what's driving this that
something must have happened something
must have happened in Africa in the
period prior to nineteen fifty-nine we
can't say how far prior because we don't
have we don't have samples from an
earlier period from that but that's
where the history comes in the third
author of this is bill schneider who's
the head of the history department the
university of indiana indiana in
indianapolis and the world's expert on
the history of blood and I was directed
to him from from patrick kappa hearts
our friends who've met Santa malden
France who'd worked in Africa is an old
he was a fellow that worked in Africa as
well and we put together an
inter-disciplinary I was my point of
mentioning it a truly interdisciplinary
team because I came to the snowing no
biology but epidemiology and bill came
into it knowing neither epidemiology but
knowing the history and in fact it's a
tale of epidemiological evolutionary
neurology history that's what stories
okay so this we lost this slide I have
to thank Lee if we I came with my Mac
formatted presentation but I couldn't
bring my computer because it busted and
we went through tricks to get him he
lost a few of the pictures but so we
have a theory it's called serial human
passage of SIV beyond sterile injecting
enabled the emergence of epidemic is now
many of you who have worked in Africa as
Jerry did in the Peace Corps and
if you had traveled worked in clinics in
Africa no the prominence of injections
and they live one study remarkable study
from Uganda from 63 showed that
something like 65 or 75 percent of the
households had a needle in the house
because they had animals and they gave
injections handled but they also people
would routinely take injections
themselves vitamin B on a Friday night
to you know to wake you up penicillin
was sold i'll show you the pictures oh
as you go for the theory first so the
theory is that by moving a virus from
one wild virus or one person to another
there's a window in which that virus
survives people before the immune system
beats it back it's not a pathogen for
humans it can't leave the simian virus
itself cannot establish an infection in
humans multiply sufficiently to be
reproducible from one person to another
and what happens though is that as it
tries to do that over let's say eight to
12 week period the virus adapts slightly
it's it's it's it's the mutations that
are more successful at surviving in the
environment of the new human host
prevail and you begin to get a
maturation of that virus and direction
of an adaptive virus to humans but then
the immune system wipes it out and it's
gone but if before in that window period
you would take a blood sample from that
person share a needle get a blood
transfusion to another person you you
infect them with the virus as you do
with all the viruses that would be in
their blood but you also give it another
release on life and this one's a bit
longer because it's now let's say able
to live three or four months instead of
one or two months and it can adapt
further and the numbers of the mutation
will change necessary to get from here
to there from them from the simian virus
to the human virus is about four or five
of those passages we calculate
okay that's not a lot but in that in
nature it would never happen I mean
where where were the opportunities but
blood-borne passage of a virus before
the introduction of medical procedure a
massive basis before the introduction of
men of medical procedures that involve
blood there was not a routine thing of
blood moving from person to person there
are animals that have blood-borne
diseases that move because they fight
over food they get plevna the poor
Tasmanian Tigers in Australia are being
decimated by a virus that spreads
because they fight over the food they
get blood similar to what happens with
smoking crack from a from a broken glass
pipe we get cuts you open up a channel
for blood-borne viruses to move and
that's what happened with the
introduction the theory goes with the
introduction of needles and transfusions
into trend needles first into Africa and
that happened in the 20th century there
were very crude injection equipments
available forms of Jackson equipment
available before that but nothing like
the scale of what began to happen
especially in Africa in the period of
the 20th century and especially the
second half of the 20th century so the
way the theory goes is with Duke you
with the first passage you have a low
this is the SIV plasma virus load how
much of the virus is is surviving in the
human to leave to leave a fingerprint
behind and the idea is that the first
the first passage of it in the first
person gets this high a level and the
second one gets that high and the third
gets the idea that you're amplifying the
virus in a way that makes it you're
really selecting for transmissibility is
what you're doing but in terms of the
viral load that that that virus can
achieve how which is a measure of its
time of survival in the human is going
up so that's that's the concept behind
it it's kind of the opposite of how
vaccines are made where you attenuate
viruses because this is natural
selection because in
in virus creation you control that in a
laboratory you know which direction the
the pathogenicity of the virus is going
you test at each time and you select for
the ones that don't transmit well and
but in this case you you you're
selecting both for pathogenicity ability
to survive at a human host and with that
transmissibility in fact the thinking in
the field of evolutionary biology now is
that the transmissibility is the
principal thing that you're selecting
for from and certainly from the
epidemiologist point of view it's music
to my ears that's what we have that's
what we understand about in epidemiology
that's what distinguishes epidemiology
from other parts of biological science
the concern not with the with the pet
that the pathophysiology of the disease
but it's transmissibility so unsterile
medical attention directions now people
have been getting injections with very
crude devices for hundreds of years you
know the Kings dying and they dragged in
a young boy and they take some blood
from others with this horrible old thing
and they pump it into the king and they
both die you know because they didn't
know about blood typing blood typing is
enchanted blood typing is invented in
nineteen ten eleven the publication is
the principal publications of blood
typing or in the early 20th century how
new these things are and the production
of what we think of as a modern syringe
is late 1900s and I try to learn this
history and the paper about the person
we published in 01 the cold the
injection says century because as I
began to look at I trying to understand
about needles and how they would
transmit because I'd work with drug
addicts and the bronze long enough that
I understood something about the
transmission possibilities because it
wasn't just HIV that was being
transmitted by by needles the earliest
studies you see a needle born
transmission of diseases of 1930s when
they found people with malaria in
Minnesota never a mosquito never could
survive in Minnesota and Nicole winter
and yet they were case was in fact it
was a blood of blood transmissible
infection and that gets parasitic
infection
but what's in human blood soon as you
open up that bandwidth to allow things
to move between people by blood by the
blood route and my mind my assertion
would be that that's a new phenomenon in
human history that I can't think of any
other condition which would have massive
opportunities for a transmission of
blood-borne pathogens other than the
development and installation of
injections and translator transfusions
into Africa they happen the same time
actually so here's the story in one in
one graph and I just note this is a log
this is a log scale for the global
production of units per year of needles
and syringes and this is the red curve
right going up from 1900 it is still
true going up to by what 11 orders of
magnitude in the course of a hundred
years and this dotted line is the oldest
known strain of HIV from Zaire Dargo of
1959 called Z 59 and you notice the
inflection points very close to that in
time because we know that by 59 the job
has been done the the virus that the
human virus fully adapted transmissible
has been created it's already spreading
as an epidemic on visible and visibly
it's very unlikely that the first virus
that the sample discovered was the first
one that existed but you've had a
process underway there especially in
this period just after World War two
because this is where the
interdisciplinary part comes in you know
what happened after world war two was
that medicine and the installation of
Western medicine in Africa and the
colonial as the colonial era was ending
those who don't know the colonial era
ends with a clunk in nineteen sixty
ninety percent between nineteen sixty
and sixty to ninety five percent of the
colonies in Africa get their
independence one way or another from
Britain from France from Spain from
Portugal Germany's had been taken away
in world war one and this correspondence
of the number of needles being produced
in the world is is paralleled by a drop
in there
that in their price so it become much
more numerous going from tens of
thousands produced in factories back at
this point hand produced factories tens
of thousands to billions produced today
by machine means and and at this point
also with the transition from metals
metal Reese reusable syringes to plastic
disposable syringes single used syringes
supposedly now of course in the
conditions of poverty in much of Africa
they never had they didn't throw away
anything and they didn't throw away
these needles they got you reuse just
like the drug users did again the story
was exactly the same story is that
because in this case the the economy
that didn't allow you to buy new
syringes for the clinics that you worked
in in Africa or the in the case of the
drug users in the Bronx the the the
dangers associated with having a syringe
for getting arrested for the equipment
that all pushed in the direction of
needle sharing and one of the was things
they have and I think it comes out of
dr. Hymas work here was the idea that
that that needle share people people
don't share needles because the trick to
this is keeping your eye on the vector
and on the virus think like a virus
things like the vector what is it that
what is it that allows that transit so
the fact that people come to the needle
is explicit in a clinic I will show you
a picture of up the road where where
people would come and get injected with
a syringe that wasn't clean which is
exactly the story the shooting gallery
we have pictures that as well so the the
drop in whoops the increase in
production so the increase in production
the drop in price they converge on the
period where AIDS and birds so you know
if it has long ears and a fuzzy tail and
it hops maybe it's a bunny and begin to
take this theory seriously at this point
so this is my contribution to the to the
science of it we began to work in the in
the field and
incumbent Cameroon we had a field
station we collected samples going back
into the 60s and the look that the
availability of injectable stuff in the
markets and found it was very easy to
buy this is the this is the local drug
store in this town and this penicillin
on that shelf and you can buy needles
there and you can buy them in the market
that convenes every Friday in the market
with you you could buy third-generation
cephalosporins at drugs perfections
diseases and infections that you
couldn't get in Yale hospital without a
infectious disease consult because
people were concerned even this is 15
years ago when people are already
concerned about antibiotic resistance
and you have you had these drugs as
flooding into these markets manufactured
in india manufacture in russia coming
down the road from nigeria and they're
in these shops and everybody gets
injections all the time then and then
these pictures going back to the it goes
back to the 20s in Leopoldville in which
was the Belgian Congo smallpox
inoculations not that there were no
injections taking place in Africa before
the emergence of AIDS in the 50s but the
order of magnitude was dramatically
different so here's the old the evidence
the pictures of that campaign the levels
of smallpox vaccinations and this is
real historical data and you see it
wherever you look trypanosomiasis
campaigns smallpox James this is this
running up for the 50s where smallpox
campaigns in West Africa but you see the
numbers are tens of thousands of
injections in the campaign's and what
happens dramatically is
the u.s. campaigns okay these are the
important ones because you note the date
on this is 1957 and these are the first
campaigns of the of the wh 0 and they
using UNESCO unit UNICEF which is you
always confuse UNESCO in one of them
administers child health program which
is the cultural one you know that's not
UNESCO UNICEF administered these
programs before w before the wh 0 was
really up on its feet running them and
and these are the the US eradication
campaign which was the first large-scale
use of penicillin massive campaigns in
central Africa Haiti and India in the
50s going in and giving single shots of
penicillin or penicillin that was
injectable it was very expensive still
although the expansion of production had
happened in the late 40s into a lot of
countries in the world something like
seventy-five or eighty percent of the
entire pharmaceutical industry of the
united states between 1946 and 1952 was
occupied with producing antibiotics
penicillin tetris tetris which is the
tetracyclic tuberculosis how new these
drugs were some you know we weren't we
were in junior high school when these
drugs were actually first available
because before that people died of
infections in very large numbers and it
said that it set the stage for four
magical expectations about what drugs
could do because they were true of of
infectious diseases while the
antibiotics still had their efficacy
without our understanding that we had an
actual adversary in the viruses and the
bacteria that would you know retreat we
weren't treating virus with antibiotics
they would come later but that these
these are organisms that are always
evolving in the face of the challenges
like the cockroaches you know get
resistant to the cockroach killers that
it's a banal story but it's it's a
baseline reality of biology so the
numbers examined and treated just jump
an order of magnitude you see these
large numbers of people in
nineteen fifty-seven getting injections
so in the period in central Africa alone
in the period from nineteen fifty five
to nineteen fifty two actually to
nineteen sixty-two that ten years about
35 million injections occurred in these
us erratic and they eradicated it was a
very nasty form of treponema disease
related to syphilis it manifests itself
in the skin it children get it from
contacting the skin hurts like hell and
it knock and it really diminishes the
workforce and that's why they were so
motivated even in colonial Africa
because 57 means colonialism wasn't done
yet and these were the first masterprint
they will be paid for by the United
Nations which the colonial powers loved
and injections injections injections and
previous to this the treatments were
were arsenicals these very painful drugs
based in toxins the old approaches to
killing parasites before the newer
techniques would develop so these were
is this the Egyptian no this is from
this cameron studies but the the
hepatitis c i think this one was about
that hepatitis c grew out of a campaign
in egypt in the 1950s using a series of
injections where you move into a village
and and and and treat a lot of people
and they had to come back for another
shot four days later and another one is
that kind of timing about right day yeah
for that for the schistosomiasis
programs the idea where that you'd move
into a village and you get the whole
series of injections like take the whole
dose series of antibiotics for the for
the course of of a week or so or of a
month rather and a perfect mechanism
given the latent infections of hepatitis
c that was some weird dormant in that
community and habit emerge such that
those communities that got the program
have ten percent prevalence figures
today of hepatitis c
you go outside of the drug using
population United States the prevalences
point zero zero one something like that
of Hep C this is principally it's some
sexual transmission but not significant
as a blood-borne disease and the disease
was let loose by these campaigns okay
blood transfusions so with with Bill we
began to look at the role blood
transfusions which I felt very stupid
but I began to look at injections and we
making logs of a number of injections I
was interviewing African patients in New
York about ejections they had back in
Africa but in this little village in
Cameroon there was guys coming down and
getting transfusions from the local
health stations from the various
practitioners from different hospitals
maybe 50 or 60 transfusions a year in a
ennis in an area which had about 50,000
people I knew it was just the tip of an
iceberg because many people went down to
tea on day or at the other city in
Cameron where the hospitals were to get
transfusions but often they were
emergency cases for malaria commonly
pregnancy accidents so transfusions grow
a pace of the injections and of course
transfusions unlike injections are a
totally efficient way of transmitting a
viral infection you know in the high 90s
vino effective transmission and here's
the years of the first reports of blood
transfusions in it throughout
sub-saharan Africa and you see that they
really jump up there are few earlier
examples they were experimenting with
transfusions they had blood typing but
there weren't blood bank said no one who
had a preserve blood adequately and but
but but by the 50s there were and you
begin to see the the development of of
the of transfusion campaigns and large
numbers it became a criteria of the
development of the healthcare system
and more of that the reason the and
here's here's the transmission rates for
the different ways of transmitting HIV
HIV now and you can see that they're not
terribly efficient but blood transfusion
to point to this in this paper was that
the high efficiency of transfusions with
the mother to child transmission being
overestimated here the time we took it
was even before any intervention wasn't
the twenties really wasn't it these are
all slides sorry so I don't want this is
the growth of transfusion in in Africa
going up to hundreds of thousands of
transfusions taking place in countries
in this period of 60 s a very
interesting thing for methodological
point of view is that as we pulled all
the data we could find from historical
archives about transfusion all the
papers published that on the upswing of
this in the in the 50s as hospitals were
establishing the use of transfusions
they publish papers to establish their
boat a fetus and take pride in what they
were doing and say we're a modern
hospital SAT there and then the papers
dropped off the off the cliff because it
was ho-hum by then it was every day it
became a routine part of medical
practice you know I defy you to find out
how many transfusions of that in the
United States today they don't measure
transfusions they measure donations the
market that the blood market is about
donations not transfusions because you
need there's a lot of this lost blood
for poor storage it's a very edge of
those who are interested in history and
public outfits and it's a very
interesting topic with as much work to
do so the the time period of the of the
of the in which the transfusions peak in
these countries all hover around the
same time the period before the 50s
where you see these inflections this 19
this 1964 actually but for the late 50s
and early 60s you see a dramatic
increase in the number of
of transfusions taking places is driving
what now is becoming not just a channel
that helped create the AIDS virus but a
channel to perpetuate it which is also
true of the injections and I don't want
to confuse so these are all of them
combined and and and they focus right
they have flow right on 1950 58 59 one
of the confusions in this work is
between the epidemic of HIV and the
creation of the of the of the of the
virus and it's easy to confound the two
because they're running in parallel
there are other changes happening in
Africa and this time urbanization
development of roads population growth
sexual habits changing modernity is
entering Africa in the period after
colonialism so you never have the pure
experiment so it's it's it's very very
challenging a kind of epidemiological
task to actually get a persuasive
argument that there was something unique
about the about the role of injection
transfusions which our group holds do
but their other groups of books
published recently saying it was a trade
routes it was the increased movement of
people the virus was gradually somehow
becoming more capable without specifying
what would enable that to happen but
look more of it was transmitting
although doesn't do the molecular clocks
and the guys who work on that very very
precise with a yes the virus was there
in 1898 but it was a different virus and
you can see from the lineage of the ones
that exist now how many degrees of
molecular difference DNA difference they
were between the new ones of the old
ones but clearly what happens in the 50s
the virus becomes epidemic ly capable in
a way that it wasn't before or you would
have had the epidemic because all the
drivers the infections the exposures of
human beings to the simian virus is the
infections of your meetings by the
simian virus is there short lasting they
to those of biological facts they don't
change over time because people are
traveling around more but the virus
itself the end point the adaptive virus
that can be transmitted sexually the
principal means of transmission of HIV
in the world are being being
cooked by this process of moving it from
person to person so our research and I'm
going to stop here because we have we
have time for some questions and
discussion the injections are still a
major source of trends of transmission
in HIV in every country that has a high
prevalence background prevalence for
that we're in Western developed
countries it's the it's the it's HIV
transmitted by sharing needles in less
developed countries although they're now
developing serious problems with
injecting drug use in many sadhus
Southern African countries but the the
heavier use of injections for routine
health care and for getting energy shots
and and and provides a background for a
continuing exposure the blood
transfusions there's been a conscious
effort to try to tamp down the use of
blood transfusions because you can't
reliably count on a testing system in
any poor country there are too many
forces against it when you get a
transfusion in Cameroon it was your
responsibility as the patient to
identify a donor was often a family
member you'd have to buy the equipment
yourself you have to pay for the HIV
test even though it was mandated the
government drill didn't supervise it
very much get a pay for the test
yourself you might not want to pay the
four dollars for the test five dollars
for the test you might pay for it and
the person you paid might steal the
money and do some of a bogus procedure
you know this corruption shot through
this a good friend who runs a blood bank
in India said to me she thinks that half
of the blood bank donations in India are
not actually screened
so we have to get 50,000 of those blood
bags around the country so amazing to do
today I try to give you one incredible
factoid in this that the transfusion
side of it if you remember that the the
belief that we know that from the 59
example of the human virus that the
epidemic exists by 1959 in central
Africa so if the epidemic starts in this
period what are the number of
transfusions that we counted the reports
and may the best estimates of the level
of transfusions and so if the epidemic
starts in the 50s by the time we reach
the 80s when we're doing when the data
are available it looks like 20 million
transfusions were done in sub-saharan
Africa areas that now have prevalence
rates in double digits that 20 million
of those transfusions were done in those
40 years in that 40 year period and
probably another 20 million has been
done since so this is a massive exposure
what's the epidemic so the point is the
epidemics up and running by here and all
these transfusions are happening with no
other point to the ADA is this that's
when the test becomes available test
becomes available at 84 85 so there was
no possibility of testing the blood in
this period and there was nothing you
could see about the person who was
infected necessarily to tell you that
they were and
let me stop with that okay look at some
time thank you